well the class of 2019 may have gotten
an unexpected torture session from
Hillary Clinton the failed twice
Democratic nominee using her
commencement speech at New York's Hunter
College to get political attacking
President Trump the Russia probe and
more watch our democracy feels far from
secure they banned Muslims from entering
the country and our government is
tearing children from the arms of their
parents at the border and locking them
in cages make no mistake we are
witnessing an assault on the rule of law
and the foundations of our democracy
what do we do when people in positions
of authority are not held accountable
when they defy request from the Congress
when Facebook refused to take down a
fake video of Nancy Pelosi it wasn't
even a close call the video is sexist
trash
so Greg Hillary was so brave that she
wanted to go after President Trump for
30 minutes but didn't say his name every
time every time she speaks you reminded
how different in irrelevant the typical
kind of political oratory has become
it's like when you're listening to her
you just go like I mean the media is
lying that they would have pervert
preferred that over Trump because Trump
has made politics interesting for once
she's just old and tired and I mean that
listening to her not as a person Trump
is a gift he has he has his made this
he's actually made it brought peace and
prosperity while delivering volatility
in his own personality so you get the
volatility but you get the success in
the achievements so you can still enjoy
his personality and not feel bad by the
way she is speaking she was asked to
speak at am at a cybersecurity symposium
yes that's like asking I don't know
Michael Moore to speak at Weight
Watchers yes it makes no sense at all
and I can't wait to hear that speech I
want to know how much they're paying her
she's speaking at she's keynoting the
fire I cyber-defence summit with the
world's leading cyber experts maybe they
can teach her something about that but
Dana they're paying her yet lots of
money
dollars right I mean come on but Dana
you've given advice to graduates before
isn't it really unfair that Hillary
Clinton would take away this moment from
them and mints to talk about her side
like so if I was in the audience like I
might say like gosh I don't feel very
inspired yeah right now I might kill us
however I did a little research like
graduates that were there they liked it
yeah I think that they're brainwashed
they are how about this they're
interested in some third u.s. senator
professors the professors tell them what
it's a u.s. senator that's how to get
your grades come on we know we know
you're just are you happy you have a
great time mr. Christie Frankie would
prefer if both of the colonies in the
White House we have it wait you're
running oh we had the real one right
okay but I mean seriously the graduates
prefer someone I think who would have
taken away all their winter and debt
right but I don't think there's any
question that they're interested in
current affairs they're smart people are
graduating with a degree and they want
to know what's going on and you talk
about somebody who knows what's going on
it's Hillary Clinton and they talk about
cybersecurity she may be the greatest
victim of cyber give a speech at this
cybersecurity summit about how to start
an illegal server from your basement
which bathroom but how do I wish hard
drives
I wish probably would give a speech
about how we're protecting America
against more Russian an affair I think
he's been harder on Russia's and any
press how you do it you don't have some
guy hand over the password that's
password to the hacker like John Podesta
Hillary won this speech was so bad I
don't think even think the graduates
through their hats up in the oh yeah you
they were all falling asleep and Dana I
would have to disagree on waters room
this weekend we have a family that was
so disgusted with this speech she went
off the rails
he was upset because he paid all this
money to have the daughter go to Hunter
College and she gets up there and
totally humiliates herself she he's
angry
tune in at eight o'clock you know what
you can't read a room either this is
supposed to be inspiring and uplifting
and no one wants to hear who's about her
it was about it was about her and I want
to know how much you got paid because
hunter college I'd do it for half that
price you make the phone sign you know
cuz their foot they still use the phone
so Craig isn't this the point that you
know you pay to go to college and then
you have paid these massive amounts of
speaker fees while these students have
all these loans and they're trying to
get into the real world and yet it's
hijacked by someone who wants to talk
about herself and issues that really I
run unrelated trying I don't see it as
hijacking I think this is completely
it's exactly what it's what they want
kids you listen to that and yeah I'm
saying what I'm saying is this has been
going on for decades they have liberal
commencement speakers they have liberal
administration's they it's just one big
liberal love fest that's why can't I
took when I see this it's like it's kind
of like again you know it's like being
surprised when you find garbage at the
dump well also a lot of a lot of
commencement speakers not and the you
didn't see it as much this year but in
2016 in particular you saw a lot of
commencement speakers use it as a chance
to make news it's not the purpose of it
that's like oh okay
what can you do to get on cable news
well if she gives me here's my theory on
why she's still staying in the game like
this she thought the insurance policy
against Trump would kick in
he would get impeached and then she
would run in 2020 as the rightful heir
to the throne because she was robbed and
then she would restore the Clinton
dynasty she kept her server on a throne
I must say amazed you guys they lock her
up because I think that your still hate
those graduates and their parents
they're going to always remember who
spoke at that graduation and they're
terrifically honored as we heard make a
lot of dough and I also remember my
appendicitis just you just love hate non
hilary's indicates wrong here okay